So here is an actual implementation from the DARPA Urban Challenge.
The Stanford trial car trying to find a way through a maze.
As you can see the maze is changing as the car moves.
This reflects of the fact that the car uses sensors to see obstacles,
and obstacles are sometimes included.
The car can only see them when they are nearby.
What's really remarkable here is that the car is able to
plan really complex maneuvers to the goal.
At any point in time we can see its best guess toward an open path to the goal.
The orange trees are A-star search trees.
They aren't exactly grid trees.
Our car moves differently from a grid-based robot.
It can turn at different angles, and each of these little steps is a different turning angle
combined with a different forward motion.
Leaving this aside you get these amazing trees
that find paths all the way to the goal using A-star.
This implimentation is so fast that it can plan these paths
in less than 10 msec for any location in this maze.
It was faster than any other driving team that I know of at the DARPA Grand Challenge
or the DARPA Urban Challenge.
The planning is repeated every time the robot cancels the previous plan.
You can see additional adjustments at place at times.
As you go through this video you can see how A-star planning
with a simple Euclidean distance heuristic is able to find a path to the goal.
When you implement this yourself the big difference
or grid implementation is a different motion model.
You have to implement a robot that is able to turn
and you have to write on the math of what it is able to turn and go forward.
This robot also can be reworked, so going backwards is a distinct different action.
Other than that it is essentially the same A-star algorithm you just implemented.
So if you want to build a self-driving car you now understand
to make a really complex, nice search algorithm to find a path to a goal.
So this is a scene where DARPA trapped our car using a barrier that went all across the street.
So the only way for the car to navigate this was to take a multi poled u-turn,
and it had to plan this all by itself using A-star planning.
The car pulls up to the barrier, realizes there's no path to go,
and invokes its A-star planner and comes up with a turn-around maneuver,
that is not particularly elegant, but it's super effective.
The car was able in this competition by itself to turn around using A-star,
find the optimal plan to do so, and move on.
Otherwise it would have been stuck forever behind this obstacle.
In this final video I'll show you a parking situation where the car has to back into a
parking space between two other cars, and you can see how the obstacles are visible,
how these other cars are visible, and how our vehicle, Jr, navigates an actual parking lot.
Again this is using A-star.
It finds its way optimally into this parking spot, backs in,
and backs out again all by itself.
The planning time for each of these A-star runs is less than 10 msec,
and the car was able to competently do this.
Even during the advance it had no clue where the obstacles were
and where the parking spot was.
That is A-star for robot path planning, and what you've implemented yourself is the core of it.
Again, if you want to turn it into a real robotic motion algorithm
you have to change the motion model.
You have to see the next class I'm teaching, when I go into
continuous models and I'm going to show you how to turn this into a continuous path.